why do you think Einstein
didn't believe his own equations and
didn't think that black holes are real
why was that such a difficult idea for
him well something very interesting
happens in
short Shield solution of the Einstein
equation
I think his reasoning was ultimately
wrong but let me
explain to you uh
what it was
um
at the center of the black hole behind
the horizon
in a region that nobody can
see and live to tell about it
as a center of the black hole there's a
singularity and if you pass the Horizon
you go into the singularity you get
crushed and that's the end of everything
now the word singularity
means that
um
it just means that Einstein's equations
break down
they become infinite you write them down
you put them on the computer when the
computer hits that Singularity it
crashes
everything becomes infinite there's two
so the questions are just no good there
now
that's actually
not a bad thing it's a really good thing
and let me explain why
um
so
it's an odd thing
that Maxwell's Theory
and Newton's Theory
never
exhibit this phenomena you write them
down you can solve them exactly they're
really Newton's theory of gravity
they're really very simple theories you
can solve them well you can't solve the
three body problem but
um
you can certainly solve a lot of things
about them
uh nevertheless
there was never any reason
even though Maxwell and Newton perhaps
fell for this trap there were never any
reason to think that these equations
were exact
ly
um and
every there's no equation
well
there's some equations that we've
written down that we still think are
exact
some people still think are exact my
view is that there's no exact equation
everything is an approximation
everything is an approximation are you
trying to get as close as possible yeah
so you think are you saying objective
truth doesn't exist in this world
the internet is going to be very much we
could discuss that but that's a
different that's a different thing
um we wouldn't say Newton's theory was
wrong
it had very very small Corrections
incredibly small Corrections it's
actually a puzzle why they're so small
so if you watch the procession of
Mercury's perihelia this was the first
indication
of something going wrong according to
Newton's Theory mercury has an
elliptical orbit
the long part of it moves around
as other planets come by and perturb it
and so on and so this was measured by
leveria in 1859 and he compared
Theory and experiment and he found out
that the perihelion process moves around
the Sun
once every
233 centuries instead of every 231
centuries
okay now this is the wonderful thing
about science
why was this guy
I read you to give any idea how much
work this is you know
but of course he made one of the
greatest discoveries of the history of
science without you know even knowing
what it what good it was going to be
so that's how small that that was the
first sign that there was something
wrong with Newton yeah
now so the corrections to Newton's law
are very very small but they're
definitely there
the corrections to electromagnetism
they're mostly the ones that we see are
mostly coming from Quantum effects
and um so so the corrections there for
uh Maxwell's equations is when you get
super tiny and then the corrections for
the
um for Newton's uh laws gravity is when
you get super big
that that that's when you acquire
Corrections that's true but I would
phrase it as saying when it's super
accurate you know if you look at the
Bohr atom
Maxwell electromagnetism is not a very
good approximation to the force between
the proton
and the electron the quantum mechanics
if you if you if you didn't have quantum
mechanics the electron would would
spiral into the proton and the atom
would collapse it's Quantum you know so
that's a huge correction there sure
so every Theory gets corrected as we
learn more
reason to suppose that it should be
otherwise how is this related to The
Singularity why is it good so when you
hit the singularity
you know that you need some
Improvement
to Einstein's theory of gravity
and that Improvement we understand what
kind of things that Improvement should
involve it should involve quantum
mechanics Quantum effects become
important there it's a small thing
and um
we don't understand exactly what the
theory is but we know there's no reason
to think you know Einstein's theory was
invented to describe
weekly curves things the solar system
and so on it it's incredibly robust that
we now see that it works very well uh
near the horizons of around black holes
and so on so so it's a good thing
that the theory drives itself
that it predicts its own demise
Newton's gravity had its demise
there were regimes in which it wasn't
valid
Maxwell's electromagnetism had its
demise there was uh
regimes in which Quantum effects greatly
modified
the equations
but
general relativity all on its own
found draw a system which originally was
fine
would perversely wander off into a
configuration in which Einstein's
equations no longer applied so to you
the edges of the theory are wonderful
the failures the edges are wonderful
because that keeps
that keeps us in business so that one of
the things you said I think in your Ted
Talk that uh
the the fact that quantum mechanics and
uh and relativity
don't describe everything and then they
Clash is wonderful I forget the
adjective you used but it was something
like this so why is that uh why is that
interesting to you in that same way that
there's contradictions that create
Discovery there's no question in my mind
of course many people would disagree
with me that now is the most
wonderful time to be a physicist so so
people people look back at at
um
it's a classical thing to say
among physicists uh I wish it were 1920.
right quantum mechanics had been just
understood
uh there was the periodic table
there was but in fact that was such a
rich thing
um that
well so that what a lot of exciting
stuff happened around 1920. it took it
took the whole it took a whole century
to sort out the new insights that we got
especially adding some experimental
stuff into the bit into the bunch
actually making observations and adding
all the experimental things computers
also help with visualizations and all
that kind of stuff yeah yeah yeah it was
a whole sort of Wonderful
Century I mean the seed of
general relativity
was the incompatibility of Maxwell's
Theory of the electromagnetic field
with Newton's laws of gravity they were
incompatible because
if you look at Maxwell's Theory
there's a contradiction if anything goes
faster than the speed of light
but Newton's theory of gravity
the uh
gravitational field the gravitational
force is instantaneously transmitted
across the entire universe
so you could you know if you had a
a a friend on you know in another galaxy
with a very sensitive
measuring device that could measure the
gravitational field that could just take
this cup of coffee and move it up and
down and Morse code and they could get
the message instantaneously over another
galaxy that leads to all kinds of
contradictions it's not it's not
self-consistent
it was exactly in resolving those
contradictions that Einstein came up
with the general theory of of
relativity and it's fascinating how this
contradiction which seems like maybe
it's kind of technical thing
led to a whole new vision of the of the
universe
now let's not get fooled because
lots of contradictions are technical
things we haven't set up the
we run into other kinds of
contradictions that are Technical and
they they don't seem to they would just
we understood something wrong we made a
mistake we set up our equations in the
wrong way we didn't translate the
formalisms as opposed to revealing some
deep mystery that's yet to be uncovered
yeah yeah and so we never we're never
very sure which are which are the really
important ones
but to you the difference between
quantum mechanics and general relativity
seem the the tension the contradiction
there seems to hint at some deeper
deeper thing that's going to be
discovered in the century yes because
that one has been understood since the
50s poly was the
uh first person to notice it and Hawking
in the early 70s gave it to really much
more visceral form
um and people have been
hurling themselves at it trying to
reduce it to some technicality but
nobody has succeeded and the efforts to
understand it have led to
uh all kinds of interesting relations
between Quantum systems and and
applications to other fields and and so
on